Joshua is on YouTube is title insurance
worth getting when buying a house never
buy a piece of real estate without
getting title insurance ever if you're
buying it from your father get title
insurance period what is title insurance
title insurance ensures that the title
is clean and that all of the transfers
of ownership all the way up from as far
back as we can find on the piece of
ground have been done properly so I used
to think that it was kind of like ripoff
insurance because you don't need it
because title insurance titles are all
clean in the real world and then I
started buying foreclosures and I have
seen so many real estate titles that
were clouded which means someone that
needed to sign the deed didn't or the
wrong people signed the deed it might
have been three transactions ago it
might have not been the person you're
buying it from did it wrong but if the
person before them and the person before
them bought it from an estate and there
were five sisters and only four of them
signed the deed you're screwed when
number five shows up she's going to own
a fifth of your land a fifth of your
house because she never signed off on
the sale that her crooked sisters did it
happens all the time
insurance from a title insurance company
says that they have checked the title
and it is proper and if the fifth sister
shows up I'm making this up obviously
but if she shows up they pay her to go
away because you have insurance that's
what insurance is for fixing broken
things with money and so that's what you
have is you have this insurance company
so guess what they do a detailed title
search that's completely different
then if you go over into a title search
or your best friend who's in the real
estate business does one I know how to
do a title search I've looked at
property and bought property my whole
life I've owned two 3,000 pieces of
property in my life so I know you know
real estate is my thing I love real
estate never buy a property well it's a
house it's a so division house how could
it be wrong it could be sitting on the
wrong lot all kinds of crap happens
human beings put these things together
and human beings make mistakes title
insurance oh by the way if you're
getting a mortgage they require you to
get title insurance in a lot of states
it's customary for the seller to pay for
it for you because they're insuring you
that the title they're giving you is
clean so it's not unusual there in some
states it's otherwise but it's a matter
of negotiation and a matter of custom
not a matter of law who pays for the
insurance if your mortgage company
requires you to purchase it which covers
them not you you can get a simultaneous
issue for about 50 bucks meaning you
have to buy the one for your mortgage
company to protect them against the
fifth sister and then you for 50 bucks
can buy an simultaneous issue policy
which is a great deal that's a super
deal right there to make sure that
you're covered against the fifth sister
or whatever other things that can happen
to real estate title and lots of stuff
can happen to real estate title